Vladimir Putin's
war on Ukraine
keeps spilling over
into Russian territory.
Officials in Russia
now blaming
Ukraine for drone attacks
and shelling in several regions today.
And that includes a map
that you can see
highlight below, Belgorod,
that is near, as you can see,
near the border.
Attacks to be appear to be on the rise
there ever since
a group of Russian nationals
aligned with Ukraine claim
to have launched an assault
on their own country.
That's a little more than a week ago.
Ukraine has largely stayed quiet
about these attacks
without claiming direct responsibility.
But a top aide to Ukraine's
president says the gates of war
have opened on Russian territory.
Let's go straight to CNN's
Sam Kiley in our Keith.
And Sam, yesterday on this show,
you told me that these
were these cross-border attacks
which are now becoming.
I think it's fair to say, more systematic
We could be seeing a new phase
in this war.
What could this potentially mean?
What risks do you see here? Some
Well, I think the risks as
assessed by none
other than Vladimir
Putin are really pretty high.
And they're exactly the results
in terms of the Ukrainian perspective
that they would want to see,
which is reaction from the Kremlin
in which Vladimir Putin has to go onto
state TV
and at a conference tell his people
not to worry, that the it's incumbent
on the government
to steady the ship this is what he said
to me, saying
today we will deal with the same issues
in relation
to ensuring the security of Russia
in this case.
Domestic political security,
taking into account
the efforts that are ill wishes,
are still making and intensifying
in order to stir up the situation
inside Russia.
Now, stirring up the situation
inside Russia is precisely
the agenda of this.
Two groups of Russian dissidents
that are backed by Ukraine and by Ukraine
and traveling
in Ukrainian supplied vehicles.
They do also have their own
funding streams.
They say
and of course,
the ongoing attacks
that we've seen in
terms of the drone attacks
since we spoke yesterday.
There's been another drone attack on
the town of Smolensk
in Smolensk
Province, quite a long way
north of the Ukrainian border.
And on top of that,
the attacks
continue in Belgorod with the governor
there saying
that two and a half thousand
people have now been evacuated
from villages around.
And he was going on a live stream
to try to reassure his population.
And in watching that live stream,
you saw a little bit
potentially of why
this is also a cyber campaign
with a lot of bogus and rather
bizarre questions being asked
and clearly by people
trying to undermine his ability to steady
the nerves of the Russian people
close to the border with Ukraine.
These are
you ask you this,
I mean, I've seen reports today.
I know you are
coming out of eastern Ukraine
and coming from the Russian system
about an assault by Chechen units.
Is this one of those stories
you want to tell me that we
need to be wary of
Well, the
Russians and
I think
the Ukrainians agree
that Chechen special forces
have been moved into the battle space
not far from back.
But this is how much has been
there is supposed to be a relief in place
going on more or less
now or concluding more or less
now between the
the mercenary group
and the regular Russian forces
there also.
Again, unverifiable reports
coming out of
Belgorod that perhaps
Russian special forces
have been moved there.
The suggestion being made by Ukrainians
is that they've been moved
from the theater in the east.
But again,
you're right, Isa,
we should take anything
the Ukrainians say about what
the Russians are up to.
Unless they
unless they have direct proof
with a bit of a pinch of salt.
Indeed, some candy.
Thank you very much.
Some colleagues
joining us this evening from Kharkiv.
Well, Ukraine's
military is accusing Russia
of carrying out
dozens of airstrikes
in the last 24 hours.
Moscow
has been targeting
the Ukrainian capital relentlessly.
In fact, in recent weeks,
video on social media shows
what's become common in Kiev people
see they're seeking safety
inside a subway station.
Two people were injured overnight
by falling debris.
Well,
this comes a day after three people,
if you remember, were killed
by debris during a Russian attack.
They had tried to enter a bomb shelter,
but it was locked.
Ukrainian President
Volodymyr Zelensky now says, quote,
Very specific individuals
will be held responsible.
Let's get more on all of this.
Joining me now is a legal fellow,
the deputy chairperson of the Center
for Defense Strategies
and the former deputy minister of defense
in Ukraine.
Lina, great to have you back on the show.
Let me start off
with the discussion
that I was having
with our correspondents,
some in eastern Ukraine.
What we have been seeing is an increase
in these cross-border
incursions and attacks on Belgorod
and beyond.
The official line,
I believe, from Ukraine
is that it's not directly involved.
So how is it involved
Well, it is really not involved.
Like there is no any kind of
official connection
or something like this.
And so always we do understand that
for all these interventions
that they are playing
well for Ukrainian purpose in any case,
because first of all,
they take the part of attention.
Then potentially some troops,
Russian troops can be relocated
to the border regions to keep the border
and not to go on the frontline.
And of course, in
in case of successful operations
and for them to go in deeper
into Russian territory,
it can be
some kind of demilitarized zone
for Ukraine
where we can
have they released the released back
less ammunition,
less artillery, shelling and so on.
So it's
obviously a place for Ukraine,
but that's only Russian citizens
who are taking these.
They officially announced this.
They officially be demonstrating
their ally calm face. Yes.
And no relation to Russia.
So what can I say about
some kind of interconnection
with Ukrainian authorities? Right.
So let me ask you this,
because our correspondent
we just had at the top of the show
some clearly
he spoke to some of these men
taking part in these incursions
they anti-Putin,
like you said, dissidents.
This is what they told them.
When I read. You aren't what she said.
What we do, obviously,
we can ask, are
Ukrainian, let's say our cranium
comrades, friends
for the assistance and planning.
What do you think about this?
Could you tell us
if this is a plausible mission?
Would it help Ukraine in this fight?
Would it make things worse?
They will say yes or no.
This is a good idea.
This is a bad idea.
So this is a kind of encouragement
and help and aid.
Does then Ukraine worry
that this may escalate this help
and encouragement
and aid
may make things
worse, may exacerbate and maybe bring
NATO's allies in direct
conflict with Russia here?
Oh, I don't understand
how it can bring the NATO
allies
in direct conflict with Russia,
because there is no in any connection to.
Well,
if only, Alina,
only if they're using weaponry
that's been provided by NATO
allies,
which is have been a concern, of course.
But but they are not using.
We saw a few pictures which were
co-produced by Russia about the WikiLeaks
so-called weak hills, which were used.
But then if you analyze this water,
which was done immediately
by many analysts, it's
obvious that this is staged photos
because these tracks where broad
they're like were located officially
in a very quickly.
Our correspondent, some in this report
speaks to these two groups and they say,
you know, they've got
have these
they've got us
weaponry, but they say they bought that.
And that's a big question mark.
So that's my.
But you understand the concern
then what are the risks for Ukraine here?
Do you see any risks with these
with these attacks in across the border?
No, we don't see risks
because we're under constant
shelling and missiles
shelling and we're in war.
This is de-escalation.
I mean, this is the talk of escalation,
which could be
we have hundreds of thousand
people suffering.
We have millions of fighting
peace and refugees.
So what kind of escalation?
We can have more tactical new weapons.
Okay.
So while it won't change
the course of war,
even tactical
nuclear weapons, Ukrainians.
86% in contact with the latest poll
says that even in case of usage
of tactical nuclear weapons,
we are not in negotiating position
we continue to fight.
So this is the decision
of Ukrainian nation,
and we don't see it as a threat.
We don't appreciate it, actually.
And I wonder
whether Ukraine is involved or not
and Ukraine says
it isn't directly involved.
I suspect
it's a win in many ways
because it's destabilizing.
Would you say that the Russian government
did?
Of course,
that's destabilizing
because actually what we see from here
that Russia was never planning
to defend itself.
And they actually don't
have a capabilities to defend themselves.
And for that,
this is great surprise
that that they absolutely
are not protected.
They always were planning
only attack and capabilities.
But when we
come to defending their territory,
they are not ready.
And every while,
just like a very simple subversion
group, can do whatever they wish
on the territory of Russia.
And for them,
this is destabilizing
and decentralization of power,
which they have
and they can
it can lead to a long range
of circumstances for Putin and for his
people around him.